شبكه معقده ومتراميه بناها تنظيم الاخوان
في الجزء الشرقي الاوروبي فباتت الدول شرق
اوروبا حديقه خلفيه لنشر فكر التنظيم في
قلب القاره العجوز الوجود الاخواني في هذه
البلدان يعيد للاذهان وجود تنظيم في الدول
الغربيه قبل عقود وكيف تغلغل الى هناك
دراسه حديثه لمركز توثيق الاسلام السياسي
وهو مركز حكومي في النمسا اكد ان التنظيم
اسس شبكه باتت متراميه الاطراف في بلدان
مثل البانيا
تضمنان وتضمان عددا كبيرا من المسلمين
فالاخوان استخدموا منظمتي اتحاد المنظمات
الاسلاميه والاتحاد الاسلامي للمنظمات
الطلابيه الشبابيه للتوسع في تلك البلدان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات